hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday and don't worry
there won't be any photos of Boris
Gelfand popping out in this video I
double-checked although if you think
about it it's hard to say if that's a
plus or a minus for a video but as we've
said we are going to show two more games
from round six of the 2013 candidates
tournament here we have a game between
team of raja baath and xi rnm now it's
it's really an intense game the game
lasted for almost seven hours and it's
there will be a question for you at the
end of this video
did skill decide this game or did lock
this side this game but we'll get back
to that so Roger bob has the white
pieces and before we showed again we do
have some photos of only two
unfortunately a nice close-up of eleven
Oregon it's a photo taken before the
game and here we have a photo of two of
them playing it's the middle game is on
the board and in the back you can see
sailor and Colson but you've already
seen that game in my previous video so
let's see the game the job of opened
with e4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 knight
c6 and Bishop to b5 so once again the
real opus Knight to f6 the Berlin
defence d3 and Bishop to c5 c3 and we
have castles now for those of you who
are maybe new to chess instead of this
c3 you might think why not simply
eliminate the defender of of the e5 pawn
and then grab the pawn well this would
this would in fact lose you the game
because now if you capture and Knight
captures here you get Queen to d4 and
now black is threatening checkmate and
also threatening to grab a piece on e5
and after we play Bishop to e3 captures
and now d4 doesn't help you because
Bishop to b4 check c3 and now Queen
captures on e4 and if you decide to win
back your piece then after Bishop to g4
Queen moves and Queen captures on g2
White will have a terrible game rook f1
Bishop to h3 is coming the only way to
defend here is Queen to E - and after
queenside castle it's it's a terrible
position for a white black will win even
more material and
this king is really looking silly only
one so don't do that
c3 instead we have castles castles by
both sides rook to e8 and now Knight B
to d2 a 6 backup to a for now the
immediate b5 Bishop to b3 and d6 rook to
e1 Bishop to e6 offering a trade of
bishops and nice to f1 Bishop captures
pawn captures so the decided to trade of
the light square bishop but now RNN gave
her a job of a semi-open a file for the
rook but in exchange he does get to push
d5 so a nice central thrust Queen c2 we
have h6 night to g3 and now a 5h three
Queen to d7 Bishop to e3 offering a
trade of bishops and here our engine
makes a very interesting decision
instead of instead of trading of the
bishops plays Bishop to FA this night is
coming to f5 at one point certainly and
this Bishop will be very useful in
guarding g7 h6 and controlling this
night in general so rook a to d1 rook a
to the 8th and now Knight does come to
f5 Queen to e6
and g4 d captures on e4 d captures on e4
and nice to e7 we have Brooke captors
and the a truck after sandy 8 and now
rook to a 1 as the pawn on e5 is no
longer defended and our job of forces
Aragon to move the rook away from the
open D file rook to e8 and now comes c4
before RN doesn't want to exchange pawns
and allow a job of 2 under both his be
pawn and now comes g5 h captors and d5
Knight captures on g5 attacking the
Queen and now Queen to c8
Knight to e7 capturing we have Bishop
captures and the now comes King to h2
Raja bow now makes open a mix room for
the roof to come to the G file and he
wants to start an attack on our against
King we have rook to a6 and now rook to
g1 so district is now very nicely placed
Queen to e2 is coming with a
of maybe Queen to h5 if this night ever
moves but in order to get the s6 rook
into the game with this nice rook lift
the first iron goes in 937 now there is
another Luke is a free to enter the
defense Queen to e2 we have worked to g6
and now comes Queen to h5 knight back to
f6 attacking the Queen Queen back to f3
and now rock to h6 and now both the rook
and the Queen from c8 are eyeing that h3
pawn it would be very dangerous if maybe
this Knight moves and if the Queen isn't
protecting it the White King is somewhat
open so here our Java finds a very nice
idea
nice to e 6 9 3 6 of course now this
opens up at the attack from the bishop
to the rook on h6 and of course you will
not be able to capture back because the
rockin g1 is pinning the pawn but Aragon
finds an excellent defense for this
simply rook to h7 now the g7 point is
defended and this night and e6 isn't
really doing all that much so Knight
back to g5 we have looked to h4 and now
rook to a-1 would have been would have
been an interesting choice because now
you really force Aragon once again to
defend the a pawn with Queen to 8 and
then white can simply continue the game
but and this is something that the quote
above the board refers to even a poor
plan is better than no plan at all and
it's something Nigel short Nigel short
and Lauren strength said after the game
as they were the official commentators
of this tournament that it really seemed
like a raja baath didn't have any any
plans during this game so he played root
2 G 2 Queen to d7 and now rook back to
g1 we have G 6 and now Bishop to c1
again a rook the rook to d1 maybe
attacking the Queen placing a rock on an
open file but even this after the Queen
moves the rook really doesn't have all
that much to do and on the open D file
note squares are available for it
so instead Bishop to c1 we have Queen to
d8 and now Russia back to e3 and now a
for pawn captures Queen captures and now
Bishop to see one once again defending
the B to pawn and the b3
Arina is attacking a resolves c4 pawn
queen to g3 first attacking the rook on
h4 rook to h5 and now Queen to d3
defending the c4 pawn queen to c6
now the c4 pawn and the e4 pawn are
somewhat weak and the iron will try to
create some chances against either of
these pawns Bishop to e3 now rook to h4
with a triple attack on this efore pawn
and here are very interesting defense
Queen captures and b3 was possible but
now after Knight captures Knight
captures and rook captures that Queen is
really out of the game and like we said
this King is somewhat open maybe maybe
it is possible to defend this but in a
practical game especially when you're
very very low in time like a javo was
not really
so after rook to h4 we have King to g3 a
very nice defensive idea now if you if
you play something like Knight captures
good ideas of maybe winning upon here
and even sacrificing a rook on h4 it
doesn't really work because after King
captures even though you're pinning this
Knight and attacking it twice and it's a
it's a really ugly square for the king
and the queen is the Queen the king is
actually perfectly fine on h4 and you
just lost an entire look for nothing so
white would be winning here
so after King to g3 we have rook back
way rook back to h8 team to h2 and now
King to g7 we have c5 Queen to a4 and
Queen to see three so the defending the
position and like we said a Java was a
really low on time here and this is move
46 what's the idea
why can you capture can you capture on
e4 after Queen to c3 well if you decided
to do this for example Knight captures
any for you get Queen captures on e5 now
there's the bishop on e7 that's attacked
and also the knight on e4 is attacked
twice and you can't save both after
Bishop here and simply Queen captures
and you just want a piece of white would
be completely winning here so after
Queen to c3 first rook to e8 now kind of
preventing this pawn from the Queen from
capturing on e5
now if course if Queen captures then
Bishop to d6 wins the Queen you have to
capture the bishop and then simply local
capture on e5 or some other way away but
the Queen is surely lost so after rook
to e8 we have Queen back to d3 rook to
the 8th now attacking the Queen and
Queen back to c3 Queen to b5
and now comes King g2 and rook to d3 so
the position is better for black but
it's hard to say is it is it winning yet
but definitely in time pressure it's
hard to find the moves here Queen to c1
we have 90 to h5 and now comes a knight
to f3 Queen to b4 Queen to e1 offering a
trade of Queens of course if you capture
on e4 then all of you see the idea what
what are the job of had in mind
simply Bishop to h6 opening up a
discovered attack to the Queen now r1
loses the Queen and the game but after
Queen e1 we have Queen to a4 and here
again at the most critical moment of the
game what do you what do you do here in
the game
Queen to e2 would have been would have
been an interesting choice simply
guarding the b2 pawn attacking the rook
forcing forcing black to do something
either it removed the rook back or bring
bring the Queen back sorry to defended
the rook but in the game a most
interesting thing happened a job of
actually played Knight captures on e5
and in time pressure things like this
will happen it seems like it seems like
there's no really there really isn't a
way for black to capture this check the
King and then win the knight on e5
because you always have this Bishop to
h6 check but the problem is Aragon did
play Queen captures any for this was
with check and now now you now you'll
see the problem King to f1 of course
doesn't work if you click into f1 then
Queen can actually capture on e5 because
now after Bishop takes like Bishop to h6
check you don't lose the Queen because
black and
to play King to f6 now the queen is
defended and even after Bishop to g5 you
you're still not gonna react to this
simple King to e6 and now white will
have to play queen capture screen
captures and now after you win your
piece back now rook to d1 check King
moves Knight f4 check King moves and
rook to d2 and this will be uh uh
winning endgame for black there's not
much white can do here
so after this Queen captures only for
her job of decided to play Knight to f3
and here it seems like okay you grab the
pawn I grab the pawn everything is well
but the problem is here our onion played
Knight to f4 and after this move a job
of resigned the game why did he resign
the game well it really doesn't matter
what you do the the most obvious idea of
course the Bishop captures on f4 elites
the Queen captures on f3 with check and
now if you go to h2 than Queen captures
on h3 will be checkmate and of course if
you go to f1 then surely all of you can
see it rook to d1 wins the Queen and the
game if you don't capture it doesn't
really matter you don't really have a
move here you're in check if you move
away from the night the King is the only
piece that's defending the knight so
Queen captures Knight would simply be
played your only idea is King to g3 but
of course then you have a king and g3
and black has a lot of winning ideas
here but the most simple one is better
captures on c5 next black and either
capture here or or even better play
Bishop d6 and create all sorts of
threats for example h4 white doesn't
really have a move here but up to d6 and
now now simply everything wins 95 white
can attack the Queen but now comes row
captures on e3 with check captures and
the knight to d3 all of the squares are
taken away from the White King only only
square available as King courage 3 and
now comes Queen to a5 check simply
moving the Queen away from the knight
that was attacking it King moves and now
Knight captures on d2 and this will be
this will be checkmate this will be you
lose the Queen and the game and of
course her black is completely winning
here
so yeah after this night to a for move a
better job of resigned the game but it's
very interesting because this is the
move after this Queen to a four by
Aragon night captures on e5 yes
Iranian did say in an interview after
the game that he was only able to break
through Raja Bo's defenses because he
was lucky because a job of played this
night captors on e5 moved but it's not
really something you can say lightly I
mean Aragon was better the entire game
he had better time management the entire
game and he put pressure on his opponent
for the entire game and of course under
pressure from the position from the
clock you simply crack and you don't
have time to calculate so I don't think
this can be characterized as luck rather
than I mean better better better game
but of course I could be wrong I'm
interested to hear what you think and
yeah that's the game another game from
round six and we will show one other
game the kramnik versus eventually came
as that game is really insane what Chuck
you once again goes into time trouble
and chronic simply starts sacrificing
pieces everything will be crazy and you
know the outcome of the game is is not
even predictable so yeah once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Matthew Goss via console Nemitz
undress beer guy Franklin and William
Fusco for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
that wild cramming Comanche game also
from round 6 thank you all and see you
soon enjoy your Saturday